unbreak fractions we deal with fractions
a lot in our lives our direct fractions
are not anything special they're just
fractions without reading them like
these okay
now just like regular fraction if for
example you are asked to subtract one
faction from another well if I gave you
some ideas like that okay
what would you do to that will you do
that
you probably want to get them to the
common denominator right in this case I
guess that would be very nice okay once
they both know that over 35 then they
can talk to each other and off you go
okay it's exactly the same here these
two have different denominators so I
need to work with them until they're the
same and then off I go
so in order to do this we're going to
rely on many of the skills of already
developed in particular factor I vision
okay so before I can do anything with
common denominators I look at these and
I take their expanded I'm even factorize
so let's look at the first one X square
plus X minus 2 I want the numbers to add
to one laws of planetary to one of the
numbers 2 and negative 1
they'll filter the job right Salman
around X plus 2 X take away 1 okay and
you can see how all this stuff that
we've developed and being good at this
if you sort of do it in sleep helps you
to focus on what this question is really
about which is the factions take away 2
divided by what we factor I see on I can
just take out a common factor of X what
does it leave you with so this is one of
the crews that you've done it either
you're headed the right direction
because you immediately see there's a
commonality right between these two
fractions ok what now when you even had
a look at things you told me the color
value should be fed fine where did you
get this from
who you want decided to get up now where
I to leave you say something like I want
to find in some this is little bit
mighty could be something like that you
could use the same strategy you would
still more or less work if you want to I
go denominator together what would you
get in this case 300 you'll be fine
you'll get the area but that's a big
number too I love to get a smaller
number I'm actually searching for not
the product of these two things
but Louis column multiple what's those
come on you did it right like what is
common multiple lot faster okay so I
think you're 15 30 45 60 is the first
one that's in common so you agree so in
this case the lowest level for 60 I've
want the lowest common multiple of these
denominators okay so here forever no
matter I notice up there going I noticed
that on this side I don't have an X you
see yeah i what the next that I need
them to be in common
I'm going to multiply the top and the
bottom to that numbers I can avoid by
the top and the bottom by X right you
see that gave me one step closer to
having common denominators okay then I
won't go me here and I say this one is
also doing something what's it missing
and if this is what missing over here so
I'm going to multiply the top and the
bottom by X plus 2 at this point look at
your denominators getting them so I have
common denominators fantastic I can now
move to my deck climb the numerators
they just subtract 5x take away that I
highly recommend even though one you
think oh I can expand this I highly
recommend you wait for the next step
because you do too many things together
and your brain forgets to do something
okay so I'll leave that factorize for
now
what's my denominator okay that was the
purpose of is putting extra English here
right to make this the common
denominator Mercator so X X plus 2 X
minus 1 so I've gotten to cover today
death combine them into one
the last sort of trailing off it now is
its numerator I can simplify right the
whole reason of expanding this is
because like why did you grab you to
experience expanding makes sense because
look this is this piece of like turf
here right that will collapse down
together in fact the like terms are
going to get are these guys do you agree
that's my new grill watch out for that
negative because them all for the right
that's an easy thing to forget the
denominated here the denominator I'm
going to leave factorized hold on a
second I stayed at the top
I didn't expand the bottom why why would
you choose to expect one but not the
other right then we called it a little
simpler have anything in the measuring
that it yeah this factorize Bowl is
simpler and there's no advantage to
expand in this guy right you don't get
anything better out of it where is there
is it advantage to expand it libre up
because now I can come like like to what
is the final line what's on the top
Thank You Axl / and I'm just going to
leave that denominator on and it was
okay so I'm trying to communicate you is
two things number one going to a
question like this it's just built in
the bedrock of the skills you vote
before satirizing and expanding right
but secondly expanding and factorize use
a question like this become something
you choose to do not something you're
told to do right no one said or if you
have to factorize at this point but to
solve a question really no other way to
go about it
you recognize our without factorizing
how am I going to work out the lowest
common multiple in the same way down
here you choose to expand the top not
because someone told you but because you
can see it I can make this simpler if I
do service